what's up my babies this is the tenth
episode of congratulations the podcast
and today's show is brought to you by
blue apron and blue apron is the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country understand that
it's number one so what I like about it
is that it's affordable and you can't
argue with that for less than 10 bar
dollars per person per meal blue apron
delivers recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals so it makes
it easier alright check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron dot-com / Congrats we're also
brought to you by Square cash square
cash is the best way I am telling you
the best way to pay people back friends
family co-workers anyone you can pay it
back your enemies with this honestly
sending and receiving money is
completely free and it's fast it's
instant understand its technology that's
how it is nowadays and most payments can
be deposited directly in your bank
account in seconds download the free
square cash app for iOS or Android and
do it now if you like me
[Music]
hey guys we're here and we're doing it
we're doing it live while my babies are
gathered round your phone in your car so
maybe you're listening with your family
you got an old radio and you figured out
how to turn it off you know what I mean
just listen to this podcast and and
listen to Chris D'Elia just kind of talk
about his his life and you know his ups
and downs over the week and his trials
and tribulations and so here we are and
if you're listening with your friend
won't you do this for me if you're
driving maybe you're going to work or
maybe you're driving on your road trip
maybe your binge listening to this like
I'm [ __ ] iron fist or Luke Cage or
[ __ ] what's the one with Jason Momoa
on Netflix I mean no that guy was in a
[ __ ] uh series it's like on season
two what's it called Jason Momoa and I
don't know it's got so much Brown in it
that's all I know is they're closer
Brown the place is brown either people
are brown everything is brown the hair
is brown
they have no blondes in the show it's a
Netflix show and if you're if you're
with yours person and you look over to
them even if you're driving I don't give
a [ __ ] if it is dangerous you'd do this
you look over them and you have a moment
with them do it like for two or three
seconds and here's what I want you to do
look at that person and while you're
looking at that person does go ahead do
it
now you're doing it there you go
that was your [ __ ] crystally a
virtual kiss for you and it was super
awkward probably if like two extremely
hetero aggro [ __ ] guys from Nebraska
we're looking at each other you guys
just kissed each other that's what
happened um yeah so it's um it's now mm
Monday or Tuesday April third or fourth
did you do an April Fool's joke yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] because uh you know
don't you know either you're a jokester
or you're not you're not a jokester for
a day okay and if anyone got
one got caught which but if anyone got
caught from more than a second I think
not not even a second like a nanosecond
like somebody wrote on Facebook oh my
god Trump got impeached and I my heart
would what and then I would wait no
April Fool's if it lasted any longer
than that
you got no head okay because you don't
have a brain but um yeah so don't be a
jokester one day of the year don't be
like a straight-laced Wall Street dude
and then all of a sudden like April
first comes along and you let your
co-workers pants on fire and then you're
like April Fool's no you just like kind
of like letting some deep deep rooted
[ __ ] stew deeper issues out if that's
how you are um but also I hate pranks I
always say that if you do pranks I think
I can't remember how we I think we
started came up with this on the set of
undateable Ron and I used to say this
Ron Funches shout out who started his
tour by the way go buy tickets to Ron
Funches tour but yeah if you do pranks
you're like people would always ask us
on the set of undateable do you guys
prank each other you guys are funny do
you guys prank each other and we would
always say that pranks if you do pranks
you're not funny that's what people do
who like don't get like who are just
like like if you're a person with a
sense of humor you're just funny and you
just like think things are funny but if
you got ever you're doing like a prank
like you put peanut butter and your
friends gloves like that's like you're
not a that's not funny you're just like
boring and you learned to do something
like that if you're like in the corner
like what you put on the gloves who
watch em watch it who computer butter in
his hands and then you just have to wipe
it off and [ __ ] it's not that cool but
um yeah so if you're doing if you like
participate in April Fool's that's kind
of like I don't know that's like one day
that's like you know what that's like
like my well it's not really like this
but it made me think of something else
my opener who will be called opener
because I'm not giving him the [ __ ]
you know what I mean I helped him out
enough
Oh Alf okay his name's Mike but he um he
thinks he's like an athlete and it
bothers me
like if a game is on it'll be like dude
you know what this is how it is it's a
Smash Mouth football and this and that
and yardage and over the line and like
but like if you get a ball and there's a
ball around he'll start tossing around
and get a really real aggressive you
know I got buddies that are in there
well in their 30s that play basketball
no yawn the Clippers no you run [ __ ]
run who's the guy that I always think of
that I can't think of right now
heya Vlade Divac no put the ball down go
to work go to a gym and just move around
you playing ball you taken it seriously
no dude you know what actually I [ __ ]
one time was playing frisbee golf or oh
no Ultimate Frisbee is what it was when
I was in high school and I was [ __ ]
around we were throwing frisbees and
somebody said to me he was a year older
his name was Mike too actually and he
said you know what it's actually a lot
more fun if you take it seriously and I
walked home straight up put the fridge
threw the frisbee walked home can't do
it that was my moment where I realized
okay done with this not Vlade Divac
leaving Murr on our test leaving my
[ __ ] uh god
Matt David Robinson leaving madama Nick
Wilkins leaving
Johnson leaving hey I got a question for
you dude malaria bear
[Laughter]
leaving me Shawn Kemp leavin miss Scott
Stiles leavin what was a [ __ ] I like
thinking of the mahjongg Stockton pass
into Karl Malone mahjongg Stockton pass
into the mailman for nicest leavin yeah
dude I know the Utah Jazz Utah Jazz dude
you know gayest name ever and basketball
Utah Jazz like just imagine being
drafted and being one of those
straight-laced [ __ ] like I just said
a gross sports dude that would be like
that would say something like dude I'm
the [ __ ] oh I'm the most heterosexual
men alive one time I was at a dinner
with a guy I didn't know him but
somebody was like you know sometimes uh
I remember what happened but it was it
was like a long time it was like I was
[ __ ] 20 and somebody was like a man
you're acting gay and he was like he was
like man the most heterosexual man you
ever ever met he actually said that and
I thought [ __ ] for guys for sure
[ __ ] five guys no doubt nobody says
that and like is like has doesn't have
some pent-up deep deep [ __ ] seeded
[ __ ] going the other way also what's the
most heterosexual man alive
what's he do what's that guy do only
[ __ ] girls all the time and watch sports
and like like what does that mean so
yeah so so my opener thinks he's an
athlete and he's not and a lot of people
do though man people are like you want
to [ __ ] play you want to play ball
and I'm like now just chill I'm thirty
[ __ ] seven gonna hurt my back by the
way
I'm 37 my birthday happened so that was
[ __ ] cool and people bug me on
birthdays because they're always wanting
you to do [ __ ] hey we should go to
dinner like you I give a [ __ ] about you
this day now because it's your birthday
and I don't want to go to dinner and I
don't want to make a thing of it and I
don't want to UM make it special I did a
show that's what I did that's all I did
was I did a show um and it was actually
[ __ ] so actually sweet because I
don't know this but my buddy Dean Del
Rey
he went on first and I wasn't there yet
and he told the crowd that it was my
birthday and when I came up that they
should all see me happy birthday and I
got on stage and everybody in the
[ __ ] audience stood up and sang happy
birthday to me and I got emotional I
actually had to tilt my head back
because I was going to start crying and
I didn't want the tears to run down my
face so I tilted my head up like I was
looking at something on the ceiling [ __ ]
it was so funny and it was so sweet man
you know what's funny man that kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] anybody up you could be
literally James Bond and be like you
know or like some some southern [ __ ]
like guy that's just like the real
blue-collar like you know live from a
family that's all I did you know and
like just go and go to work that's what
it is cow gonna machine bullet and then
if like 50 people sang them happy
birthday of they're like in their
establishment be like mom oh boy
well anyway let's get back to work
fellas hey you looking up at the sky
Hank yeah I mean just I thought there
was some on the ceiling hey I'm gonna go
to the bathroom and then he's in the
bathroom you look like it's funny how
that [ __ ] get you it's like that scene
in a Good Will Hunting what he's like
tonight fault
by the way I wish that scene was money
when they it's not your fault he's like
I know that's the best acting ever it's
not fault yeah I know
sorry fault I know I do I know si your
fault I know it's not your fault I know
I wish that scene lasted honestly the
only thing that would have made that
scene better if it for real lasted two
and a half minutes if it went like it
Vaduz was drawn out that long and it
would be so weird and then he starts to
cry after two and a half minutes I know
I know just after two and a half minutes
is Robin Williams it's not your fault
Matt Damon I know it's not your fault I
do I know two and a half minutes and
then just [ __ ] and then he ended up
crying like this that would have been
the best scene I've ever seen in my life
but it already is top ten um so uh yeah
it was my birthday I don't really do
presents or whatever get I don't get
people gifts so I don't expect to get
gifts and [ __ ] got some nice cards got
some nice virtual cards got some nice
shoes got some nice things you know I'm
a hooker with these shoes by the way man
I love shoes so much I'm like a hooker I
practically had sex for money um but uh
yeah I don't I also when you're singing
happy birthday dude but whenever
somebody this is what happens like they
sang happy birthday to me there was like
a hundred and fifty people in the room
and I didn't know was going to happen by
the way the videos on my Instagram if
you go look at my Instagram everybody
stood up and did it it was really sweet
if you give a [ __ ] but when I was what I
every time I on a birthday I think I
used to have this girl in drama in drama
class when I was in high school a man at
the grind my [ __ ] gear this is like
young Chris when I first came into that
like this is when I was first becoming
who I was and I realized the [ __ ] that I
liked and didn't like this girl when we
would whenever there was someone's
birthday and drama god I can barely do
this right now
without cringing I'm already cringing
people would sing happy birthday to you
and when they would get to that
you part she would go very in a deadpan
way cha-cha-cha she would go so it would
be like happy birthday to you
cha-cha-cha happy birthday to you
cha-cha-cha oh my god dude I my heart is
heavy right now like it is so cringing
my ass fall tighten dude - first of all
it's you know she does it every time
even if even the first time so that's
infuriating okay second of all the
deadpan like I'm not doing it but I'm
still it's funny but look how funny it
is cuz I'm not acting like it's funny
made me want to rip off my shirt like
Hulk Hogan okay but the worst part is
that she's making the birthday song
about her and it's supposed to be about
the [ __ ] guy's birthday it is and she
would sit there and every time
somebody's birthday was and I knew it
was [ __ ] coming - I knew it was
coming every time
happy birthday and I you gotta sing you
got to sing or others you're the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're not gonna not sing it's
like the guy who doesn't dress up for
Halloween the biggest [ __ ] is the guy
who doesn't dress up for Halloween even
though you're an [ __ ] if you dress up
for Halloween so this is a lose-lose so
just you know so she would sit there and
I knew it was coming happy birthday and
here it [ __ ] comes and then she would
be in the background cha-cha-cha oh
drove me crazy dude I would just watch
her and I wouldn't even be angry I would
just be like what kind of a person
develops into somebody who does this
first of all first of all cha-cha-cha
like though that's the anything she
could have been like put up a brown butt
cha-cha-cha the cutest [ __ ] I'll buy a
sword dude
I'll buy a sword innocent what I'm
saying that kind of [ __ ] makes you want
to leave immediately and go buy a sword
that's how angry I was I'm not I'm not
even I'm just I'm not even I don't even
mean I'll use this sword I just mean it
makes me so like okay got it
I'm gonna buy a sword now I collect
swords now that's what happened you
[ __ ] did cha-cha-cha now I collect
swords it makes sense I know some of you
guys are like why would you buy a sword
it makes [ __ ] sense cuz why did you
start collecting swords listen in
[ __ ] episode 10 on my podcast and the
cha cha cha woman that was his origin
story that was his origin story um I
wanted to by the way this is how [ __ ]
crazy it is this is our off track I am
on this pot not off track but like um I
there was a girl that came up to me the
other day and she was like you know I
like your podcast and I said what why
and she said because it's the journal
and and I and I thought it was funny but
it's kind of true like I'm just writing
this [ __ ] down in my in my in on my
audio space that'll definitely somebody
will [ __ ] take a clip sometime and
put it on [ __ ] somewhere and it'll
bury me for sure you'll cut it together
it'll be like it'll cut it together
it'll seem seamless and it'll come out
like you know what [ __ ] Koreans or
something it'll cut it all together and
you'll be like you said this and I
didn't know you didn't say that um and
and so yeah but so it is kind of like
that and it's definitely
stream-of-consciousness but what I
wanted to start off the podcast saying
and here's the thing that uh because I
did just happen I was like I'm I talked
about this on the podcast as soon as I
sit down didn't happen yet and we're
[ __ ] 20 minutes in but um uh I was at
my coffee spot that I go to to get my
coffee I rushed out to do it
I got to start the day doing that I
can't just wake up and then sit and do
the podcast I feel like I need to go get
my coffee and here it is drinking it um
but uh like before me there was this guy
who came into the coffee shop and he was
dressed literally like a neo neo in the
matrix and he had on boots over his
skinny jeans that were like flapping out
like over it they were really high like
he was Lemony Snicket's or some [ __ ]
tight black pants a sweater that looked
lot a sweater I'm sorry like a sweat
shirt like t-shirts wet fabric that had
um like it was like terry cloth but it
looked like an old like a boyfriend's
like a like a hot chick in the 80s would
wear the shirt and it would be like off
her shoulder and you'd be like a kid
you'd be like man that's the first time
I ever saw that that's the first time I
ever like my dick moved you know she's
hot and you'd be like eight you'd be
like Daddy why do I like that girl
and your dad would be like well you know
I don't know girls are really nice to
look at sometimes and you'd be like uh
and that's how you'd learn it so that's
the shirt he at and then um a long like
robe like kind of a thing that went down
passed over the back of his knees and it
was black and it was furry and but not
like crazy furry but like almost like
the same material as the boyfriend shirt
thing that I was describing or the girl
shirt hot chick in the 80s and he had
long hair like David Guetta and beard
like David Guetta and looked like David
Guetta and now that I'm actually talking
about it I think maybe it was David
Guetta okay but it wasn't and because
because this was the part that made me
laugh like this guy got all done up put
his [ __ ] tight black jeans on his
dopest [ __ ] boot Lemony Snicket boots
his hottest [ __ ] hot chick as in the 80s
short-sleeve terrycloth shirt his
[ __ ] neo robe that had by the way a
belt on it that was open that like was
like dragging almost long David get to
fit hair and face and like was the
illest got like probably got out of his
car and thought like yo I'm in a movie a
little bit though and got to the gun and
they were like and he was like yeah I'm
on my [ __ ] coffee ordered it like a
dope [ __ ] and then the guy was
like and what's your name who was the
coffee for hey can I get a name for the
order and he says Ralph like hey that's
[ __ ] hilarious that no matter how
dope this [ __ ] thought he was
his parents still named him Ralph and
that's what he goes by with all the
boots and all the extras and all the
[ __ ] key chains and [ __ ] robes and
whatever the [ __ ] sunglasses he still is
ralph let me tell you something man
there's nothing funnier than that there
are things as funny but that's it this
[ __ ] guy he's put his parents don't
have that she does boots or pants or
shirts or whatever this [ __ ] guy came
out of his mom's [ __ ] and his dad was
life was like looks like a ralph and the
mom was like yeah and grew up to be in
his head the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know he
still has to go to Coffee Bean and Tea
Leaf and [ __ ] say Ralph that's the
kind of [ __ ] I like that's that [ __ ] I
do like when a guy goes into a coffee
tea being dressed like neo and also
David get to Faison hair and also has
limine Snicket boots but then is this
for his name and the coffee and still
has to say Ralph does that should I do
like if [ __ ] who was the guy who raps
at chief keef oh forget it dude I'd
listen to that song on repeat and never
stop a guy who works in a Coffee Bean
and Tea Leaf at 11:00 a.m. with Lemony
Snicket boots and LMFAO pants and a robe
that looks like me would wear and then a
tease hot chick t-shirt on with David
Guetta long hair and David get to face
but then when his ass for a car named
for his order of visco fee he still has
a rough because that's the name that his
parents chose even though they're
nothing like a mess they should I do
like dude if that was the song forget it
I've literally become a DJ so I could
play that song on repeat at Skybar all
the time I'd be a resident DJ at Skybar
or some houses so I could play that song
all the time do you understand me and I
put that's that [ __ ] I do like and then
that's the title of the song if I've
made the song and in a parentheses I'd
call it that whole long thing you know
how like rappers actually rappers don't
just do that like any [ __ ] song will
do that I love I love that [ __ ] is
hilarious when they're like yo this is
the song title but also in parentheses
this is also the song time you know I'm
talking about like it'll be like in the
mountains this song is called and then
in parentheses will be called it'll say
free bird in the mountains well that's a
real song but in the mountains and then
parentheses by the lake I would have
[ __ ] is a song about just call the song
outside you cover all the bases in the
mountains in parentheses by the lake
pick a [ __ ] area [ __ ] you can't
call a song two [ __ ] things you can't
call a song two things you call song one
thing cuz it's one song you got two
songs you can two things make a song
called by the mountain you're in the
mountains and make another song called
by the lake
in the mountains over by the lake that's
where I love blossom make two songs in
the mountains is where we met and but
and then another song by the way is
where the love blossom you got two songs
dude you're halfway done with the
[ __ ] now I don't know what to call it
didn't know what to call it so had to
put the parenthesis that even supposed
to signify what is there in parentheses
thing why put it in the parenthesis I
like this title to save that's the title
for another [ __ ] thing you're blowing
your wad dude you blowing your wad he
blowing you wat ah man I just
immediately imagine like someone hating
me listen to this podcast and like
wanting to [ __ ] murder me which is
like made me like really like [ __ ]
like happy and also like but also like
also sad I guess I guess yeah I guess
that's that's uh I don't know I don't
know what the [ __ ] I was trying to say
sorry guys I'm not though you know um
all right guys
I want to talk to you about a little
thing called blue apron okay and blue
apron is the number one fresh ingredient
recipe delivery service in the country
and it makes incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone the cool thing
about blue apron is honestly
first of all Scott you know everything
you want beef chicken pork seafood and
it's from responsibly raised animals but
you know you don't waste food it's it's
easy the produce is sourced from farms
that practice regenerative farming and
it delivers 99% of the continental US
and 99.5 of food deserts so that's a
that's a a really a really great thing
for you and your family and speaking of
which on households you can build strong
family bonds cooking I mean that's a
thing that can help families learn and
grow together and honestly the research
because you guys know I do tons of
research the research shows that blue
apron families cook nearly three times
more often so you know what I mean you
want to have a strong family or not if
you want to have a strong family which I
want to have a strong family you get
blue apron so uh go to blue apron calm
slash Congrats and you can check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free with free shipping I'm
telling you you will love how good it
feels and tastes to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait that's blue apron dot-com /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
hey how about that square cash square
cash is the best way to pay people back
friends family coworkers enemies dogs
sending and receiving money is fast and
it's free and they can be deposited very
quickly and received very quickly it's
instantly it's honestly it's the fast
it's the fastest app to do this with the
other apps are not as fast so you want
the the worst ones or you want the
better ones you want the better one so
go a square cache you know a lot of the
other ones that are like a social
network with like is sharing you can you
can like the the payments that's not a
good idea why would you like payments
and why do you want people to know when
you pay someone else back right I don't
want people to know that if you're going
to do something shady then you don't
want that and also even if you're not
shady I don't want people know my
business all right Square cash also does
not require both parties to have an app
installed which is way better and it
offers the pot it offers instant
deposits unlike other the other ones so
let me ask you guys a question do you
guys use myspace still no okay well then
don't use don't use anything but square
cash because Square cash is like using
the the cool new one and I'm telling you
that so you can download the free square
cash app for iOS or Android now okay you
could do it now
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now by the way I actually
I is still a thing though you can share
money on snapchat you can send people
money on snapchat but that was a thing
though at least it was a thing was there
was a snapchat cash that was something
snapchat cash hey I'm gonna set hey you
know what I'm gonna send you a picture
of my dick and 450 like what hey you
know oh hey
here's my a go I'm gonna send you an
eight second picture of the inside of a
puss
no so 35 bucks like weird I look in my
app on snapchat and why the [ __ ] will
but yo I see on Twitter though a lot of
these girls are like sign up for my
exclusive count on snapchat to see my
[ __ ] and [ __ ] like a exclusive
content they'll be like exclusive
content oh really
is it a deleted scene Nats just you
[ __ ] oh dude do I get to see the
deleted scenes from [ __ ] trolls the
movie or do I get to see you bits and
pieces I mean come on
oh hey send me money on snapchat imagine
being like hey dude you gonna pay me
back
yeah here here's here's here's what
Elliot no no dude you know what just
send it to me on snapchat when you send
a picture with your dick send it over
when you send the pic of your dick for
seven seconds I remember when snapchat
was like people were like you should get
snapchat and I was like nah cuz I'm not
sending pictures of my grundles to
people and then and then it became like
a legit thing and then it used like a
promoter like dj khaled wasn't showing
his [ __ ] sweaty taint another one hey
dj khaled can i get set up dude see did
you can't just sent me a picture of his
[ __ ] balls really yeah get him to
send another one I didn't see it I
missed it it was seven seconds do you
think he could send another one um yeah
but then it became like a real thing and
then I am [ __ ] with it I just put up
my show dates on it and people would
come up and they'd be like hey I know
you from snapchat and then I was like
it's weird uh TV doesn't even [ __ ]
matter nowadays I've been a [ __ ]
be four five six years people are like
hey I know you from my buddy brent was
saying from undateable he was saying
that he's did a Netflix special and
undateable and all the [ __ ] and people
recognized him for some [ __ ] YouTube
[ __ ] he did the other day that's
hilarious
really [ __ ] really really makes you
feel weird when that happens especially
cuz you know these YouTube red kids are
like uh god these kids are living the
life man I saw a girl on Instagram like
shooting today and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this idiot shooting and she has
like you know a millions of followers
I'm like what does she do
what does she do does she shouldn't have
a job at a bar so her job is she's not a
a comedian I guess she's a model
I guess but then she makes like funny
videos but like she and she that she
just that's her job like she made that
her job and that's amazing um but like
shooting today and I looked at her
snapchat and it was just like awful like
pictures of like dancing and like like
these like some of these people like
just like have dope lifes and that's
what they sell and you follow them and
you and everyone's basically a
Kardashian their own version of it
there's like a spectrum there's Kim K at
the [ __ ] 100 end and then at like 90
end there's like the [ __ ] Khloe and
then at like the 80 and 80% there's like
the [ __ ] other one I don't even know
and there's no Khloe and Kim and then it
goes less and less I like it's Kendall
probably as well higher and then it goes
less and less until like you know I'm
somewhere on there and then you get like
my producer Chris who's like four which
is by the way better and then you got
like zero the guy that like doesn't have
any social media that's a spectrum now
but uh
yeah and I'm just like watching this
snapchat because I'm curious and I'm
like this she's there's like dancing
around there's a party they're like got
sparklers and it's like 3 p.m. and I'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening what is
this day you know what day it is Sunday
it's not a special day
it's just Sunday and she's got sparklers
and it's always handsome mixed-race
dudes around it's so weird it's never
it's like a it's like a either like a
goofy ass white dude or like handsome
dudes that are the same race as the rock
and they're just like dancing and
they're going what that's all they're
doing and sparklers and cakes and drinks
and then they're looking at the camera
taking pictures with 40 people by what
is this day you're having what day is
this you know what day that is bond day
that's what day that is you're having
bond day it's a new day it's not a day
it's not [ __ ] Monday
cuz that's when you start work it's not
Tuesday cuz you're in the middle of work
Wednesday's hump day Thursday it's
almost Friday Friday is your last work
day Saturday you get to go out and live
your life sunday is a relaxing day to
get ready for the week I didn't describe
that day that she was having in any of
those days so that day is bond day if
you're having bond day congratulations
man
you made it bond day is for people who
don't have jobs that somehow make money
doing things and if you light sparklers
if you like [ __ ] sparklers one one
day a week that's a bond day if you're
lighting sparklers you've achieved bond
a bo nday that's when the shit's turned
up that's when the [ __ ] you're wearing
booty shorts or you're a mixed-race dude
and you're handsome as [ __ ]
and you gotta clean as [ __ ] beard or
you're a goofy ass white dude with a
neon green shorts on and you're doing
this face blowing or you're taking a
picture with seven chicks and you're a
ten but they're all eight bond day and
you're at a [ __ ] W somewhere and
somehow [ __ ] herbal tea is sponsoring
you hey stop scrubbing your body with
coffee what the [ __ ] is that
every other picture is a [ __ ] chick
scrubbing her body on with what do you
do that I want to get real out of shape
first though and just scrub [ __ ]
coffee grinds all over me and then take
a picture of me and being like guys buy
this anyway my point is don't send money
on snapchat
that's for showing your dick or
promoting your schedule or showing bond
a um Bo nday hashtag it man that's
what's up dude you know what for real
find these people on Instagram this is
what I'm asking you find these people on
Instagram you can tag me so I could see
it but then hashtag bond or just hashtag
bond a don't even tag me on it just
hashtag bond a on these people find
these people on Instagram they're dudes
too by the way they're not they're not
just chicks they're people can have
bonding hashtag Bo nday and then later
on in the week I'm gonna go look at the
hashtag bond days and I'm gonna laugh
and giggle my [ __ ] 37 year old white
ass off in my house that's for me dude
thanks in advance cuz I can't wait to
see these [ __ ] bond days do it [ __ ]
[ __ ] bond day dude [ __ ] bond day
dude
Monday that says [ __ ] I do like D I have
sparklers in a place that's a W probably
and you're in an apartment complex maybe
also you're in blue shorts and you're
hanging out with 7/8 in year 10 and also
you're with mixed-race dudes that are
really handsome that have clean beards
and a goofy white guy that's skinny with
neon green t-shirts and that's that
should I do like spin that song at
Skybar I'd become a DJ I'd become a
[ __ ] DJ ah man mm-hmm
drinking my coffee um so what that's I
don't know man I really [ __ ] went
hard on that Bondurant and now my back
hurts dude so so I'm just [ __ ] 37 is
[ __ ] I can't believe that man your
result is you know how people are like
you're Zoli like here's a deal like I
got the greatest job man I go on stage
and I go literally like Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing and I make money and all right
I'll tell like a joke about [ __ ]
shoes and and then I make money and like
I do it all around the [ __ ] world
well world I guess now I'm going to
Australia soon gonna tell you soon
guinness trolley Essene ganna and uh wow
I I gotta tell you man I completely lost
my train of thought uh-oh
yours oh yeah so that's my job so like
I'm young ish because of that but like
there's 37 year old dudes that are like
50 you're not I'm talking about dude I
saw a guy at the airport the other day
and he was getting moving or moving
along like at a real slow pace and this
guy was older and and I was like this
guy's older and they and they asked the
guy cuz you know if you're over 75 you
don't to take your shoes off because
they think if you're over 75 you can't
[ __ ] have lethal shoes I guess you
get to keep your belt on because they
think you don't have [ __ ] you don't
have a lethal belt if you're over 75 or
have a bomb in your buckle and they said
to the guy they were like are you
are you over 75 because if you are you
don't have to take anything off cuz just
moving real slow and he said no I'm 69
and I was like whoa that guy is my dad's
age and my dad is like young he's like a
cool young hip [ __ ] like
[ __ ] you know what I mean like
he's like he's like Jerry Springer like
he's [ __ ] walks into a room and like
who's that guy he's got a nice hair he's
like George Hamilton he's got like nice
silver hair and he's just cool he's got
like red shoes you know like Nikes he'll
wear like a [ __ ] black like a blazer
and pants and a button-down and like red
Nike Air Max hey hey swag my dad's 69
hey swag
nobody would ever be like are you over
75 because you need to and this guy had
on like cargo pants a shirt [ __ ] and
was hunched over like didn't know where
he was you could ask him where he was he
might be like the grocery store you're
like no you're in terminal 6 and he was
69 he was my dad's age my point is I'm
37 and ah I think people are like you
know because of what I do I don't have
[ __ ] kids and I'm not like CEO of
Crate and Barrel or work at you know I
don't know I'm not like a manager at
like a grocery store that like people
like kind of forgive and like let you do
things like like [ __ ] that David
Guetta guy was talking about the coffee
bean he was my age but he was like he
had like cool David get to face and
obviously didn't have a real job like I
did like me like we both have probably
the same like he was probably DJ or some
[ __ ] and but like you you you forgive it
because of what you subscribed to in
your life and that's crazy because it's
all mental really your mental space and
then other people's too because they are
they believe what you believe
right but you just sub to come to the
lifestyle of having two three kids as 37
you wear that blue button-down and the
khaki pants and the dot you know the
doctors and the [ __ ] Doc Martens or
the shoes the boat shoes with milk socks
and you're just that guy I don't know I
don't know if what I'm saying is the
right thing but you guys know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about
my my [ __ ] babies delivers you know
I'm talking about delivers um I must I
want by the way this is a cult in no
[ __ ] way is this a podcast it's a
cult
all right I'm gonna get a [ __ ] tent
and we're gonna go somewhere one day and
we're going to talk about all this [ __ ]
you're going to believe it we're gonna
have posters and signs and [ __ ] you do
you don't do dude my utopia we're gonna
be somewhere in Salt Lake City outside
like Provo or some [ __ ] one time I took
a road trip with my friend up to Provo I
literally have no [ __ ] idea why I was
going up there it's going to Provo Utah
with my buddy Trenton and Gavin two
buddies Trenton Gavin even though those
guys even though it sounds like those
guys would just be characters in books
like novels I actually have two buddies
named Trenton and Gavin and I was taking
a road trip with him and it wasn't a
symbolic novel and we went to Provo and
I made a joke where I said literally
this well that's the whole point of the
joke I said I don't want to go to I'm
said I'm so glad you guys are coming to
with me on this road trip because I
don't want to it would be really cheesy
if I went to Provo alone haha and it's s
bad but we laughed hard and Trent laugh
so hard that he cried
provolone provolone is cheese for the
[ __ ] dingbats out there um those are
the kind of jokes you make [ __ ] eight
hours into a a road trip Thanks my
producer just went road trip and I don't
even know what's up you're as old as you
[ __ ] to put out there I guess is what
I'm trying to say all right I'm going to
check the hashtags babies I'm a look at
some of these hashtags for some of you
guys I know you're trying to gain the
system because you're trying to [ __ ]
do it late in the game and do hashtag
congratulations pod on Monday and
because you took the guys advice I
forget what his name was but he
definitely definitely learned how to
game the system it's way to we all
learned honestly that day a few episodes
ago that it's way too easy to gain the
system and that I really need to look
back on the hashtags because gaming the
system honestly is probably the end the
end of podcasting as we know it so it's
really a scary thing and I'm glad that
guy told me about gaming this out easy
and flawed my hashtag questioning was
because of how easy it was to game the
system sometimes I think about that
during the week and I laugh at that guy
so thank you that guy
congratulations plod hashtags do you use
this is from Doug at captain Stabbin 82
change it now that boy if I ever heard
of change it there it is captain Stabbin
82 huh change it nonetheless here's this
question Doug do you use music at Chris
do you use music to get you hyped before
a show if so what music gaming the
system he writes no I don't I don't use
music
I don't listen to music to get hype I'd
rather just I drag actually might what
I'd like to do what I like to do before
I go onstage is be in a conversation I
like to be in a conversation with
somebody that I'm just [ __ ] with and
we're making fun of each other or
something that I feel I gotta go on a
show and then I go on I take the energy
onstage that's what I'd like to do but
it has always happened and usually
conversations that I'm in before I go
onstage are not the kind of conversation
I want to be in because it's like
somebody telling me about a microphone
or what the or there's a clocks on the
stage on the Gaya call get it hey by the
way why did 40 people tag me in my group
project is to get your attention on
Twitter this is for a greater good
I had like so many people tag me in that
I don't know what that means but you got
my attention now and also stop tweeting
it um uh this is from Jay Keith at
Jordan Jay Keith good there you go hey
everyone learned a lesson from Jordan
Keith pick your [ __ ] name close to
you handle so you don't have to change
it who's your favorite comedian
congratulations pot you know I don't
know if I could pick a favorite comedian
but I have guys I like to listen to and
I'm sure I'm leaving some out if I talk
about this so I don't want others to get
not that they listen to this but to get
offended actually you know what I'm
going to do instead of naming the guys
who are at the top of the game right now
I'm gonna name the guys who I think more
people should know Brody Stevens is
hilarious he's like a [ __ ] loose
cannon on stage and just just really
funny Bryan Callen a lot of you guys if
you're 10 minute podcast fans uh which
is the podcast I used to do a long time
ago with Bryan Callen he's great Mike
Costa is great really funny guy Fahim
Anwar hilarious all those guys you got
to check out I probably follow them all
on Twitter you should too
those guys are all really funny
comedians now obviously I'm leaving out
the [ __ ] guys at the top of the game
[ __ ] you know louis c.k Dave
Chappelle bill burr all those guys but
I'm talking about guys that I think you
should show some love
here's another question nicholas andrew
at by nicolas underscore a good enough
good enough name there you go close
enough
Chris Thalia have you ever had a
threatening situation after kicking
someone out of a show congratulations
pod gaming the system um I I never I've
had guys threaten me but only from the
audience and then they got kicked out
like [ __ ] you and I've had people get in
fights with themselves like other people
fought in the audience and I'm sitting
there and watching it now mediating it
all of a sudden I'm Joe Rogan in the
[ __ ] UFC announcing it but no I've
never had a threatening thing happen I
mean somebody's been like I'm gonna [ __ ]
you up or whatever but it like not like
almost where it like it was about to
happen or I was in front of it's always
like I'm on stage and he's in the
audience and I'm super happy that that's
never happened because I wouldn't want
to get into a fight what's your
relationship with uh sorry I missed it
what the [ __ ] happened would it go
what's your relationship this is by aj
mcdougal age under school at aj
underscore mcdougal
chris alia what's your relationship with
Will Sasso and Bryan Callen like post
ten-minute podcast
PS trying to gain the system so hard man
you guys are really my running this
[ __ ] gaming this system thing into
the ground and I love it keep doing it
they're my best friends they're two of
my best friends they're great I just saw
him the other day I see Bryan all the
time does he just stand up and I saw
will the other day because he came out
and it was really [ __ ] good to see
well they're great guys and [ __ ] I
literally love them um let's see what
we got this a good question by Joe
underscore books and his name is Joe
books at Chris D'Elia do you think
you'll be bringing back your snapchat
characters I miss Ivan and Phil uh you
know I yeah I guess so I don't know
honestly I I love uh I loved doing that
but I get like bored as [ __ ] but I'll
probably do it at some point again I
just like to do I like to do uh I like
to do what I want to do and I don't want
to do it and then once sometimes like
people say like hey dude do I do this
then I like start to lose interest in it
because I don't like when people tell me
what to do I think is deeper issues um
oh god here comes Chad Saban at Chad
Saban have you ever told a joke during a
set that bombed if so what was it bro I
mean literally every comedian has bombed
[ __ ] 14 million times so um but well
not literally 14 many times by the way
update on Leo a lot of you guys wanted
to talk about you know you guys like Leo
and and he's the French guy that stars
bro saucier you know that guy I'm gonna
I texted him I told you any never SEP
texted back and then he texted me back
like five days later sorry dude can't go
I have to leave country for the weekend
and the ID thing is annoying but working
no but next week I huh ite huh alright
then right away afterwards seven no
sorry seven minutes later I'll just see
next week and dude I checked some vids
comics are good invite not invite mark
Normand hell's funny also what is funny
hey what I'll just see next week and
dude I checked some vids comics are good
invite mark Normand hell's funny also
what is funny mark Normand is [ __ ]
funny but why is he saying what is funny
then he writes oh ok dude see yeah then
he writes five minutes later your stuff
too
then he writes exclamation point ha then
[ __ ] six minutes later he sends me an
H just the letter H then two minutes
later he writes k-space
D de did this guy get run over by a
truck I mean it was so funny dude this
guy leo I followed him on Instagram and
some of you guys caught to it and then
[ __ ] went on his Instagram I went saw
SIA what a bunch of [ __ ] dicks you
know alright well you know what we're
wrapping up uh thanks for listening and
remember to check out my upcoming show
dates which is on my website Chris
D'Elia calm I will I will be in
Australia if you're listening from the
land down under check my website for
that but I got West Palm Beach I got a
bunch of [ __ ] coming up Baltimore you
know all these [ __ ] places that I
haven't been yet and you can also you
can also remember to tweet me at hashtag
congratulations pod and if you can try
and game the system then do that there
and ask me questions I always hit those
at the end of my show and please I'm
asking you rate and review the show
because it really helps me and it helps
the podcast help the life of the podcast
it makes me want to keep doing the
podcast and that would be really helpful
if you rated it and you gave us 5 stars
or however many of the most stars I
don't know and and we are now on
stitcher a lot of you guys asked you
when you gonna get on stitcher well
we're on it so go ahead and check it out
if you'd like and if not go [ __ ]
yourself
or just listen to it the way you've been
listening to it on YouTube or iTunes or
whatever the [ __ ] you want all right and
please remember
for blue apron to check out this week's
menu and get your loot first three free
meals free with free shipping by going
to blue apron comm / Congrats and don't
forget to download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android thanks guys see
you later my babies
[Music]